معنا من الناصره وديع عواوده الكاتب
والخبير في الشان
الاسرائيلي وايضا من رفح الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ياسر ابو هين اهلا وسهلا بكما سيد
عواوده ابدا بك مشاهد كهذه كيف يمكن ان
تؤثر على الداخل
الاسرائيلي نعم تماما هذا السؤال وجيه
ونحن نتحدث عن اليوم السابعه الساب بعد
المئه ولذلك من المتوقع طبعا وانا اتحدث
عن قراءه
ل بما يجري داخل الحلبه السياسيه
الاسرائيليه وبالاستناد ايضا الى تصريحات
وتسريبات وقراءات اسرائيليه فان مثل هذه
العمليات الدمويه التي تجبي اثمان من
الجيش
الاسرائيلي تنتج ما هو معروف بعلم النفس
بالتنافر المعرفي هذا كوجيف ديسونس مهم
بين الروايه الاسرائيليه الرسميه خاصه
العسكريه التي تتحدث عن مكاسب وانتصارات
والمزيد من التدمير والمزيد من القتل
والاسر ثم تاتي هذه الانبا باء اللي تقول
ان كذا وكذا من الجنود الاسرائيليين قد
قتلوا واصيبوا وهذا بشكل عام يعني يؤدي
الى زعزعه الروايه الاسرائيليه واذا تكت
الاسرائيليين ايضا تتعرض الى المزيد من
الضرب نتيجه عوامل اخرى خاصه ان هذا مجلس
الحرب بات يعني منقسما وكل ما فيه يتسرب
الى الخارج كذلك الامر الثقه بالحكومه
ايضا باتت مهتزه اكثر فاكثر لكن هذه
الخسائر اسرائيل حساسه للخسائر البشريه
اكثر من اي وقت مضى فما بالك والحديث الان
وهناك تساؤلات وعلامات سؤال وريبه وشك بان
هذا الكابينيت بان رئيس الحكومه نتنياهو
ربما يريد اطاله امد هذه الحرب ليس ان هذا
ما تقتضيه الامور العمليات والعسكريه
والاستراتيجيه بقدر ما هي رغبه باطاله عمر
هذا الائتلاف وهذا بالتالي يزيد من
المتوقع ان يزيد المزيد من التشكيك المزيد
من الغضب ولذلك هذا ربما يرتبط او يلتئم
مع عوامل اخرى من شان ان تؤدي الى المزيد
من الاحتجاج والمزيد من التظاهر ضد
استمرار الحرب في حال ان ازدادت الضغوط
الخارجيه ان ازدادت الازمه
الاقتصاديه استمرت المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
الرد وفي المقاومه وفي تكبيد الجيش
الاسرائيلي الخسائر هذا من شانه بالاضافه
الى عوامل اخرى ان يؤدي الى ارتفاع منسوب
المراره منسوب التشكيك في قدره اسرائيل
على مواصله هذه الحرب خاصه وان في وعي كل
الاسرائيليين لا تزال اصداء تصريحات بايدن
الذي وصل بعد ايام من السابع من اكتوبر
وقال للاسرائيليين تعالوا وتعلموا من
تجاربنا في افغانستان والعراق القتال داخل
مناطق سكنيه ماهوله امر ليس سهلا وما الى
ذلك والان هذا يعني يختبره الاسرائيليون
على جلدهم ايضا بالاضافه طبعا الى ان
اسرائيل تحاول تعويض ذلك من خلال النار
والدمار والتدمير ولذلك حتى صحف دوليه
كبرى كنيو يورك تايمز والجارديان اليوم
تنشر تحقيق تحقيقات واسعه عن الدمار
المريع والهائل الذي يذكر بالحرب العالميه
الثانيه داخل قطاع غزه وهذا
يعني يضع الاسرائيليين امام المزيد من
التشكيك اذا كانت كل هذه النيران لم تسكت
نيران حماس فمتى تنتهي الحرب اذا y